thank you
all right Adam Adam where'd you grow up
where are you from originally I'm born
and raised in Huntington Beach Orange
County California
uh grew up in you know middle class
neighborhood Huntington Beach uh right
down the street from the beach actually
uh surf Life Surf culture skateboarding
running around my parents were
originally alcoholics and addicts and
they kind of got out of the life and uh
got sober into recovery and became
pretty successful individuals when I was
three years old they divorced and so I
was kind of brought into that whole
world of
having a separated family
my dad hated my mom my Mom hated my dad
each one of them kind of talked [__] on
each other uh continuously
and that affected me
greatly actually
um through that I kind of withdrew from
the whole family life and started
getting to the more of the surfscape
culture
um
and uh right around Middle School I
started getting into sports
my dad pushed me into sports unwillingly
but I fortunately found an escape
through Sports
um and so
foreign
it was kind of trying to balance the
my life in sports in my life in the
surfscape culture of uh you know
Southern California living on the coast
and uh
you know I started to excel in in sports
and so it kind of Drew me out of
that whole world of Surfing and skating
and being on the beach and and the punk
rock lifestyle and uh
I continued to progress through the
levels of sports I played on traveling
Club teams at baseball I ran cross
country I played football and uh and
then High School came and um
in high school I kind of just shot out
as far as excelling in sports
were my world at the time and uh
I only focused on Sports
um you know and when my parents I would
come home I wouldn't really associate
with my family too much it was more or
less
sports during the day you know come home
at night I didn't do homework the only
reason why I got through school was
because all my coaches were my teachers
um
and then uh you know I started to dabble
a little bit and and smoking weed and uh
partying on the weekends doing that
whole kind of weekend warrior thing and
uh
but it never really affected uh me
playing sports
uh at all you know because I was so
focused on that
um
played Varsity four years uh out of four
years in high school I made all varsity
teams as a freshman
um and I got the encouragement from my
parents but because of what happened
younger when I was younger uh didn't
really even matter it was more or less
proven to myself and my escape from you
know my separated home reality
um
once I
got into my junior year of high school
my weekend partying kind of started to
grow if you would and um
it it really started to affect my
lifestyle and at that point
in that yeah that young I had to really
choose uh what my Pat what I wanted my
path to be and so I kind of walked away
from the drugs and alcohol in high
school and put my whole heart into uh
training and focusing on my sports
um and about my junior year my mom had
gotten cancer
um
she had ovarian cancer and uh
you know
anybody that happens to or anybody that
knows anybody that has had cancer that's
close to them it's uh it's pretty
devastating
um but through chemo and uh you know
Western medication my mom was able to go
into remission and uh you know I was
kind of able to focus uh
back on my path of sports baseball and
cross country and football and all that
stuff
and uh
things really started getting good uh I
had Scouts coming to look at me I was
getting scholarship offers
and I uh
I really started to look forward in life
and and smile because uh I was on a kind
of a trajectory of uh quote unquote
success
and uh
shortly after that the cancer came back
from my mother I wasn't really seeing my
father that much because I was focused
on being there for my mom and trying to
balance
you know being there for my mother and
my sports and my kind of extracurricular
activities what I still dabbled in which
was the parties on the weekends and
stuff
and uh for the second time my mom went
into remission somewhere
in the beginning of my senior year and
uh
so I was able to focus back on other
things uh you know all this in between
bouncing back and forth between my mom
and my dad uh and them hating each other
and me kind of withdrawing slowly each
time because
really you know I mean uh the only thing
I had at that point because my family
life was in such shambles uh was either
the drugs and alcohol
or the sports
um somewhere towards the end of uh my
senior year the cancer came back quickly
this time for my mother they told us
that it was terminal and um
at that point uh it really started to
affect me knowing because I always grew
up Mama's Boy I was a mama's boy 100
even though my dad encouraged and pushed
me and supported me in sports I felt
like the only reason why he pushed me
and encouraged me in sports because he
was kind of living vicariously through
me because he had thrown his life away
for drugs and alcohol he was also a
Hells Angel
um
and that was his identity for a long
time and he had kind of lost his
identity from when he was younger and
did Sports as well so I felt he was
living vicariously through me pushing me
so hard into sports
um but I enjoyed it I enjoyed Sports I
enjoyed the the accolades that came from
playing sports I enjoyed the camaraderie
and the unity that I found in sports to
kind of Escape my my home life uh and
and in reality my home life
really wasn't so bad living in Southern
California Suburban neighborhood on the
coast
um
but some reason I just I just wanted
more than what I was getting at home and
so when my mom went into uh her third
term on cancer and they told her it was
terminal
I had scholarship offers and I decided
at that time to not accept any
scholarships and transfer to a JC local
and I would play sports there and kind
of ride that out until my mom's time
came and she passed
which ultimately did happen
and when she passed uh I kind of just uh
I kind of Tanked everything in my life
took a downward spiral I ended up
getting an injury
playing baseball and as a result of that
injury I was prescribed uh Norcos and um
you know once that injury healed and the
Norco prescription ran out I um
you know I found Oxycontin and then
because of the price of Oxycontin I
wasn't able to afford and keep up that
lifestyle and by this point I had just
forgot about everything you know I mean
they're getting and using of those pills
is really what consumed my life and
that's what I focused on and uh
I really had no other option at that
point in my own opinion
um and uh so I found heroin and uh the
first time I ever used heroin was uh
erroneously I am an IV user was an IV
user uh
and and it's crazy how when I think uh
how quickly things deteriorated in my
life
uh it really baffles me
because Within
a year of my mom passing
shortly after high school uh you know I
I had dropped out of college uh I had
became addicted to heroin
um I'd become addicted to the street
lifestyle and I ended up going to uh to
prison for my first time you know I'd
done a few little times Stinson County
and uh
it it really my life really shifted at
that point when uh I caught that case
the first case which was a residential
burglary and a firearms possession
um
you know because I was trying to get
the substance that I was addicted to the
opiates the heroin uh by any means
necessary you know
um
once I caught that case and uh I made it
to prison
um
you know I saw who the cool kids were in
prison and I I eventually joined a a
prison not eventually it was actually
happened quite quickly uh because I was
always seeking some type of uh outside
validation I was always seeking some
type of uh Brotherhood camaraderie Unity
uh family uh lifestyle that I didn't get
at home when I was growing up
and uh
joined a prison gang very young and um
if anybody's you know been a part of
that lifestyle they know that that
you know there's there's not really any
way to move forward or or grow in that
lifestyle other than uh going all the
way in and uh
that progressed extremely quickly
um you know doing things in prison and
doing things for uh
for the cause the gang the family uh in
the prison life is is absolutely no fun
man uh but but I enjoyed it and I was
kind of getting really uh
you know a lot of things that I thought
that I needed but uh you know it turned
out to just
run my life into the ground I didn't do
too much time on that first term
uh
you know I got out but as soon as I got
out I hit the ground running you know I
mean
um
the the getting and using of my drugs
the getting and gaining clout in the
lifestyle on the streets was uh
something I craved and that's really all
that I did
you know and uh
it didn't take too long for you know the
rest of the people in my family to see
realize and understand that that was the
path that I was on and even though
even though the
you know they they tried to be there for
me
um and they tried to get me help I
didn't I didn't want any help you know I
was kind of
stuck in the monotony of uh of the gang
life and the street life and the drug
life and uh
I really didn't want to get out at the
time and I wasn't really aware of the
consequences that I would suffer later
down the line as a result of that
lifestyle
so really
um I just kept going and I kept going
hard and I went all in
um and that started
really
a whole revolving door vicious cycle of
go in
to jail to prison get out
get strung out on heroin
you know I've been shot I've been
stabbed uh you know I I basically
embraced everything that had to do with
that lifestyle and accepted the fact at
that point in my life that I was either
gonna die in a gutter or I was going to
die in a prison cell and uh you know
these were the cards that I was dealt
you know my parents were alcoholics and
addicts even though they made it through
to the other side and were able to get
sober I
kept the mindset that I was biologically
predispositioned to be this person
um
and uh you know I really didn't have no
way around that at the time no guidance
no structure in my life
um
no way further forward other than uh you
know the way I was going
and so I continued that really
destructive
you know mindset path trajectory
whatever you want to call it and I kept
moving forward with it and uh
slowly but surely
um
everything around me began to
deteriorate
I would gain a few little things in life
because I was trying to play this
small part of on the other side trying
to appease my family trying to appease
the people in my life that were present
prior to me going to prison but
all I could really focus on was getting
back to the streets and uh
putting a needle in my neck really
um
and uh
not too long after my second prison term
in my mid-20s I met a girl I got sober
for a little while and she uh
ended up getting pregnant with my son
um
and my sobriety lasted a few months
there
I remember being in the hospital when he
was being born and I had to run down to
my car because I was starting to get
dope sick I was starting to feel the
withdrawal effects from an experience
the withdrawal symptoms from
uh my heroin addiction and uh
I was barely able to get down run down
to the car
and uh you know get well do my issue uh
and be back upstairs just in time to see
my my son come out
but uh you know the crazy
thing about that is that I thought that
that was my cure-all my son was born
I've always wanted a kid and that was
going to be my incentive to walk away
from
My Lifestyle to everything I had chose
in the previous 10 years up until that
point and in reality that was that was a
joke man that was a joke because as soon
as he was born we went back home
and uh I was right back out on the
streets you know and and
for about a couple months
I tried to balance being a father and
living at home and focus on my family
when in reality my entire attention was
you know right back out on the streets
and eventually I was kicked out and uh
at that time homelessness was uh
was my only option uh you know I
so I hit the streets in uh Santa Ana in
Orange County and uh that became that
you know that started another vicious
cycle of uh living on the streets with
nowhere to go everything around me was
consisted of uh using drugs
uh robbing people robbing businesses uh
robbing houses
by you know by really any means
necessary uh if I had to hurt someone to
get what I needed
um you know I would do that if I had to
lie cheat steal manipulate anybody in my
path to to get me to the other side of
uh what I wanted
um that's what I was going to do
ultimately and through all of this I was
told
you know by by the few people that were
still left in my life
uh that I was only hurting myself I was
only uh
doing this you know to me and that how
can I be hurting you guys uh you're not
living the lifestyle that I'm living and
uh
in reality that was kind of just a front
that I put up and I didn't realize later
on in life and when my perspective
shifted the two that that was all just
uh it was all just bullshits and
justification and rationalization and
lies I told myself and other people so I
can take continue to to use and and live
on the streets and and gangbang and
all right
you know so all that comes to a head
um
I ended up
catching another prison term which was
you know really a relief at the time
because I was able to get up off the
streets and I was able to get away from
the street lifestyle and get a bed get a
shower get some meals in me and uh
but in reality it's kind of a catch-22
because you would escape the street
lifestyle but you would go directly into
the system uh of the CDC the California
Department of Corrections where it was
run by you know gangs in organized crime
and uh
you know you'd be right back doing the
same stuff doing the same [__] you were
doing on the streets uh only you were
doing it in a lockdown facility uh
and uh I mean
I I really
I really don't
I really don't like
I really never realized uh
the pain that I was going through
you know and then I I the only
the only thing that I knew how to work
through that pain was was to continue to
inflict pain on those around me
um in prison I sold drugs
in prison uh
you know I I did things for for the
powers that be
um you know whether I agreed with it or
not uh
that was uh somebody somebody had to get
stabbed someone had to go
uh you know I just followed the rules
and I figured if I was the one
doing all that stuff then I you know
that stuff wouldn't wouldn't reciprocate
back on me and um
to this day I really kind of uh I still
have nightmares about it diagnosed with
PTSD as a result of uh you know violence
uh
inflicted on me and inflicted on others
uh in the prison system you know I
suffer from nightmares still to the this
day
um
and
that was about that was about three
years ago when I paroled and uh as soon
as I paroled
uh
he was right back to the same thing you
know I went and uh got a handout from
one of the homeboys you know picked up a
significant amount of uh heroin got a
firearm and uh
you know in all aspects of that
lifestyle I was kind of on top of the
game right I had money I had a hotel
room
I had uh you know I had a firearm I had
dope I had everything that I needed to
be successful in that lifestyle you know
I mean in that world I had everything
that I needed to be successful in my
opinion
um that lasted about about two weeks
until I know about three weeks until I
got strung out again and it's it's
interesting so every every night before
I would go to sleep if I did sleep I
would uh I had a little routine that I
would do I
I would make
two shots of heroin uh I would cook them
up in the spoon
and I would do one issue for bed and
then I would have my bottle of water and
my issue for me when I woke up in the
morning and uh that way I could wake up
sick pound the water you know and uh
kind of get my vascular system going in
order for me to find a vein and and get
well
um it's completely demoralizing really
when I think about it now uh but I woke
up the next morning with no no thoughts
in my mind uh on getting sober no
thought in my mind
the night before of going going to bed
that I was planning on changing my life
um
and I woke up the next morning and I
kind of just laid there for a second and
I was I was quite sick I was extremely
sick actually because my habit had
gotten so bad I was at that point
just three weeks out of prison uh I was
up to you know anywhere between four and
five grams a day of uh of heroin
you know in in California
um
it was it was easy to get insulin
syringes so I can IV my my drugs all you
had to do was go to the local pharmacy
and uh you can buy 10 packs of syringes
so I was using about three to five grams
of heroin a day three weeks out of
prison
um doing the most as as far as that
world is concerned uh and I I woke up
and uh
I don't know you know you can call it a
spiritual awakening you can call it uh
well you know God shot whatever it is
that you believe uh
I woke up and I just I I I literally
looked at the ceiling and this [__]
motel with you know I mean and I and I
just said to myself I don't I don't want
to do this anymore
I don't I don't want to live like this
anymore I don't want to continue to
kill myself slowly because up until this
point in my life I uh
I had overdose 26 times I had been in a
coma twice as a result of my heroin use
um
and that that had never steered me away
from continuing to go straight back to
you know what was what was what was
killing me
uh you know I had been shot I'd been
stabbed
um
you know shootouts everything that came
you know fighting cops stabbing cops or
CEOs uh you know shoe terms uh
every every everything that came with
that lifestyle and and all the
negativity and toxicness that brought to
my life and the destruction that caused
around me I I never even sat back and
and realized that I was
doing such damage
to
to myself to those around me and living
a complete and utter and utter lie you
know
um
so I woke up that morning right and uh
I looked at the ceiling and I was I was
like I said I was extremely sick
[Music]
um
and uh I almost I get emotional you know
what I mean because it's it's it's a
it was it was kind of like my my
my jumping off point right uh
to where I finally realized that uh
there's there's so much more to life
than uh
than the sidewalks of of Orange County
California and la and and and selling
dope and and carrying a gun and and
being a gang member and
creating destruction everywhere I go and
and taking from society and and uh
it just kind of hit me at that one
moment you know and by this time I have
a
I've met a new girl trying to get sober
again and uh she had two daughters and
uh you know through the times of
of the haze where I could kind of pull
myself away from from the street life I
uh I built a relationship with these
little girls uh you know I had no idea
where my son was at this point in time
no idea uh his mother
had uh disappeared with him
and uh
you know I really didn't deserve to be
in that little boy's life at that time
and it wasn't until later when I got
sober that I realized that uh that was
the right thing to do because I I hated
her for it
I I developed resentments uh because she
took him uh to God knows where and I had
no way of seeing him
and like I said all these kind of you
know played through my mind in in a
in a short period of time laying in that
that motel room bed uh and I I called my
girlfriend at the time who was sober uh
you know what she was doing with me I
had no idea because uh
but um
and I called her and I said you better
you better get down to this hotel room
and she goes I'm I'm at work right now
you know uh
I can't leave and I was like well
you need to leave
because this is this is life or death
and at that moment in time it was it was
life or death and uh I don't think if
she if she didn't get there as quickly
as she she did uh I would I would be
here today to be honest
um
she came in and uh I told her that uh I
handed her you know I had a hand her to
the firearm
and uh I handed her the dope that I had
and I said uh
you know I want to change my life I
don't want to do this anymore and which
this had happened so many times prior in
my life like this like the the repeated
of experiences of trying to get sober
and and trying to change but there it
was it was never for me or myself it was
always for for someone or something else
like my Pro officer or or my children or
uh the girl at the time or or my parents
uh you know who had both passed uh
um you know my mom ended like a tracking
backwards my mom ended up passing away
she died in my arms took her last breath
as a result of cancer and then uh
somewhere in between my my second and
third term my my dad had uh contracted a
degenerative brain disease uh cognitive
brain disease that uh just ate him away
and then he ended up dying in my arms
and um
as well and uh
you know the pain and never being able
to heal from those situations or never
developing the coping skills to to heal
from those situations kind of
perpetuated and exacerbated my my drug
use and and living in in the street life
um
you know so all that accumulated and
kind of culminated in this moment in
this hotel room that day and uh
you know me still being a drug addict I
handed her the the heroine and
and she went to go to the bathroom to
flush it and it was a significant amount
you know I mean uh and uh
you know I went and took it from her and
wouldn't let her flush it and uh ended
up calling one of my homeboys and and
they came and picked it up and
you know
um so it was quite the scene that this
is this hotel that day and uh she had
called a friend because she had already
been in recovery she was had already had
some time sober and uh
he let me uh
he let me come to his house uh which he
owned some sober livings uh and um
let me detox on his couch
um because I I didn't get he wouldn't
give me a bed in the sober living
because he didn't think uh I could make
it you know because up until this point
in my life I had I had lied to everybody
and told every [__] story in the book
and tried so many times to change but
could never let go of uh the kind of
identity I had created for myself never
let go of uh you know persons places and
things and the behaviors that uh kind of
drove me to this point and and
to the gutter really in my life
and uh
but but
I was ready to surrender really man I
was I was willing to do the work that I
needed to do to change my life and uh
was scared had a lot of [__] fear
because I didn't know how to to live
life on life's terms I didn't know how
to to be an adult I didn't know how to
be a productive member of society I
didn't know how to be a [__] man I
didn't know how to be a man and uh
um all I knew how to do was was was hurt
people and and Rob and and steal and uh
survive in in the California Department
of Corrections you know whatever
facility I happen to be at on that term
um
that's all I knew you know what I mean
and I know how to shoot drugs and how to
shoot dope really well
um
you know I and uh
so there I I went to the sober living
and on this couch and uh
man it was probably the worst uh you
know I'd kicked heroin and and Fentanyl
and and and benzo Xanax and and so many
times man but uh
you know uh whatever the powers that be
the universe God whatever soft fit that
uh you know this one would be uh
worse than anything I've ever
experienced in my life
um
you know sweating [__] myself puking uh
going through uh every aspect of it
um
but I was willing man
and the way I look at it now the way I
put it is uh the
the pain I was experiencing throughout
those years in prison and on the street
the pain I was experiencing finally
outweighed the fear of change that I had
um
and it was really a blessing uh you know
and from that moment forward I got to
work uh on myself
um you know I grabbed onto some some men
in my life that had walked through the
lifestyle that I had up until that point
and kind of got out of the gang life and
got out of the street life and got out
of the prison system which which never
occurred to me that I I was I could do
that right you know I mean that I can
discharge my my CDC number uh that I
could actually get a job and a career
and be successful I could actually be a
father I can actually be a husband I can
actually be a man right because my my
whole perspective on being a man was the
clout that I accumulated in the streets
by uh you know doing the things that
come with uh that accompany that world
and um
and and so yeah I just I just got to
[__] work man I just got to work
um
uh I'm a member of Alcoholics Anonymous
it saved my life
um
you know
I I really didn't know how to do
anything in life I didn't know how to
get a car you know other than steal one
I didn't know how to pay insurance I
didn't know how to pay rent uh I didn't
really have any skills any life skills
that uh could contribute to uh success
so I I really was a a baby or a child
in a grown man's skin learning how to
live life on life's terms right and it's
interesting because all the things when
I tell my story you know when I when I
speak at places I tell my story and uh I
it was so easy for me to do the things
on the streets and in the street life
and in the gang world uh and in the drug
world it was so easy for me to do those
things uh because it was what I was used
to and I was comfortable there and uh
when I got onto the other side of the
fence and was trying to learn to be an
adult right uh I would tell people my
story and they'd be like you know like
this is the easy part like they couldn't
they couldn't understand the things or
the path that I walked for so many years
and how that wasn't difficult for me but
on this side of the fence learning how
to be an adult and and do the adulting
thing uh was uh was was easy to them you
know but
so I kept I kept grinding
um trying to do the right things for the
right reason uh at that point in time I
had cut everybody off in my life that I
was associated with prior to making that
decision to get sober you cut everybody
off I changed my phone number I didn't
talk to anybody I shut off all my social
media
and uh you know
um because that's what would always
bring me back I would I would have kind
of a an epiphany for a moment in time uh
in the past and and I would oh I'm gonna
get sober I'm going to do this I'm gonna
I'm gonna change my life I'm gonna stop
going to prison I'm gonna stop hurting
people and uh I'm gonna stop gang
banging and uh
but I never I never cut out the person's
places and things that that uh
accompanied that lifestyle and as a
result of that I always went right back
you know I mean uh right back to to the
dirt right back to the mud right back to
the gutter and uh you know this time was
was serious and it was real and and uh
so like I said I got to work you know I
mean I I started hitting meetings I
started uh
you know I got a sponsor I work steps
um
you know I got I got right and did the
internal work that was necessary in
order to reflect my external life uh
because before
as a drug addict you know what I mean
um we're real good at painting this
pretty picture on the outside you know
kind of this uh
high definition [__] front of uh that
everything is good in life when really
uh inside I was just destroyed for so
many years as a result of my parents
divorce
um
you know both my parents dying in my
arms and never really uh healing from
that and uh the pain that that caused in
my life and so I kind of
inflicted pain outwards you know what I
mean but every time I would talk to
anybody I would you know I was doing so
well I was feeling so great
and uh
you know I started to do the internal
work that was necessary you know I
started cleaning house
um and uh through recovery I I have
found
[Music]
um
you know it's super cliche and if
anybody's involved in a or anything like
that they know that uh you know uh
clean house
you know and you help others and uh you
know I started doing the pretty pretty
major inventory on my life and uh I met
some people who are
the closest people to me in my life uh
you know I uh
I started working with these people and
uh
and doing things uh really to to give
back right you know I mean to get back
with what was so freely given to me is
what we like to say
um I I work today
um I'm a certified substance abuse
disorder counselor uh I'm currently
going to school to get my degree in
Psychology
um
uh with some of my friends uh my closest
friends my family my fiance we started a
non-profit organization
and basically our goal for this
organization is to help addicts and
alcoholics and people that suffer from
mental health uh or untreated mental
health
um
get resources to get into treatment and
get the mental health treatment they
need to get the the substance abuse uh
treatment that they need and uh what we
do is we provide we help provide
clothing for people that are trying to
incorporate themselves back into uh you
know
work and getting jobs we help set up
resumes
we help get you know things that you
need to to really just
be a functioning member of society
social security cards birth certificates
IDs uh you know jobs we do uh interview
training
um we help build resumes and put these
people put put addicts and alcoholics on
on on the path to changing their lives
and incorporating themselves back into
society you know
um
and that that really is a
is where it's all at for me today you
know I I have a career
I have a life
that that I can't even put into words on
how grateful I am for it you know and
that's the important important thing for
me is is a
is the Gratitude right
um
you know gratitude is is an action where
you know and I'm a firm believer in what
what am I doing today to show
those around me that I'm grateful so uh
you know today my my life is focused on
my family my life is my life is focused
on helping others and as a direct result
of that I've been I've been blessed with
uh
with with a beautiful life
um it's crazy going back to uh my son
not being anywhere that I knew where he
was right I was um I was sitting in uh
when I was in that sober living
and I was in what's called IOP which is
an intensive outpatient co uh program
and due to covet I wasn't able to go
into any drug treatment
or anything like that and uh so I had to
do everything uh virtually right uh
treatment program
and uh my phone was ringing and uh it
wouldn't stop ringing so I had to excuse
myself from my class and uh
I answered the phone and it was uh my
baby's mom and uh how she got my phone
number it was a brand new phone that's
another story right I have no idea
[Music]
um
but she said uh
I said hello and and she and I knew it
was her right away and she the first
thing she said was uh hey I heard I
heard you doing good I heard you're
sober
and I said yeah you know I'm I'm doing
what I can I've done some work but I've
got a long way to go
and she told me uh
you know would you would you like to see
like to see your son and uh
I said yeah I would I would love that
you know and um
it's crazy how things work uh in in life
when uh you're doing the right things
for the right reasons you know what I
mean and and your motives are are uh our
Pure
um because I didn't think I was ever
going to see my son again and in real in
reality I my actions dictated that I
didn't really deserve to see my son I
wasn't doing anything to be a father I
wasn't doing anything to deserve to have
him in my life and uh
you know I was able to see him and uh
I hadn't seen him in six years
you know he uh
and and now today what's crazy uh as a
result of of getting sober and changing
my life and and on the path that I'm on
my my son lives with me full time now
um and uh you know I get to take him to
school
and uh
you know basically teach him how to be a
young man and raise him which is
something I could have never dreamed of
when I was [__] sitting in a prison
cell trying to uh you know
figure out who's got to go next or or
what I got to to put in my ass to make
money that day you know what I mean
whether it be drugs or whatever because
that's the way things are handled in
prison you know I mean uh
uh
and I just never foresaw
where I am today you know I mean uh
working with with other people and
helping other people that suffer from
what I suffered from and uh helping them
find what I have today uh
is uh
something I can't put in the words the
the feelings that I get when I when I
help someone else the feelings that I
get when I help when I see a 20 year old
male or female come into treatment and I
get to be their their counselor and I
get to uh
you know see them
grow and start to heal from the similar
things that I suffered from
in my whole progress and my whole
process and my addiction
uh it's unexplainable you know and
that's why I continue to do what what I
do on a daily basis you know and and
it's uh it's really uh
it's really a tough battle because
statistically
um
you know
one out of every 10 people are going to
make it you know and especially with
what's going on in the streets today uh
with fentanyl and stuff it's it's really
um
it's really sad
you know in the in the three years I've
been sober I've been to
[Music]
probably 60 or 70 funerals uh
you know and and uh I thank God that you
know with all my overdoses and stuff
that I you know I mean there's there's a
reason why I'm here and there's a reason
why I'm able to do what I I do today and
uh I'm glad that I had the experiences
that I did and I was able to walk away
so I can share my experience strength
and hope with other people and and uh
you know pray that that they can find a
way out as well
um
it's really beautiful man absolutely
beautiful excellent talk thank you man
yeah no worries